declaraciones del ex Primer Ministro
italiano Silvio berlusconi han desatado
este miércoles el caos político en
Italia en audios que han filtrado en la
prensa italiana se oye a verlosconi que
elogia al presidente ruso Vladimir Putin
asegura que ha relanzado las relaciones
con él cuenta que han intercambiado
cartas amables y pone en tela de juicio
la estrategia militar y política de la
Unión Europea y de la otan en Ucrania
audios que han desatado la ira de
Georgia melón y la líder de hermanos de
Italia principal partido político de la
coalición de derechos ganadora de las
recientes elecciones en Italia melón y
quien es la potencial candidata a
dirigir el próximo gobierno italiano
respondió con un mensaje tajante
diciendo que pedirá Claridad a todos los
ministros de un eventual gobierno suyo
ya que según ella Italia hace parte de
la alianza atlántica y quien no esté de
acuerdo con esto dice melón y no podrá
hacer parte del gobierno palabras
fuertes en un momento crucial para el
país es ya que este jueves el presidente
de la república Sergio o matarela
empezará La Ronda de consultas con los
partidos políticos para encargar la
formación del próximo gobierno aquí en
Italia